[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up guys happy Monday
it's me Eric that's Nick as you can see
new week new streams as gup-c ride has
mentioned today we're gonna check out
MBA live 2018 now that it's officially
came on actually last Friday I think 2k
18 comes out tomorrow but we played the
prelude demo so we kind of got a feel of
that so Nick's kind of play both I
haven't yet but we're gonna play some
head-to-head later and I should have
figured out where to put the picture in
picture but we'll figure that out in a
second so this is the game obviously
we're gonna check it out play their
story mode which is the one the one the
league in the streets so you made a new
character right I did I created one I
selfishly created myself wait my dream
version on the weekend can we can we can
totally do this maybe we don't so we
know what that looks like
there is loogie Nick Margo sick all
right let's create let's create somebody
we're gonna create a monster
we actually I know we tried - yeah - gay
teen this time around you can definitely
create some weird-looking dudes cool so
we're gonna try creating monster just
want to say shout outs everyone tuning
in we'll try to answer as many clothes
and we want to call this guy I don't
know you did gaming spot last time that
was already weird enough no it's dumb
let's see no we're we're gonna call them
screw it we'll do it
gamespot games that was lame and it is
it is lame
okay all right what yeah buddy
okay it's gonna look really weird
because there's a lot of like text
convos okay and so it's gonna be weird
cuz they're gonna refer to you as a game
but that's fine all right commentary
name we don't need one
well you know what I should show you
guys what this is all about so you can
kind of pick like a name that sounds
like yours so let's see so maybe there
is something along the G's that could
possibly work
let's see not quite so we'll call him
Gaines that's that's what they're gonna
call us
that's quite a game game Gaines spot
alright are us a California we are in
San Francisco how you feeling about the
Nike switch I'm all about it but well as
you can tell by the Jersey I'm wearing
all the V I got that old-school all the
adidas stuff is really really cheap well
now it is because they have to get rid
of masks you ready yeah where do we go
to school maybe we went to two K it's
not even out yet I don't think
Aiden green unless I'm crazy unless it's
on like early access the game doesn't
come till tomorrow when we're checking
out live because we played two K 18
already we went to songs out so what
what's our jersey number I don't know
what did you make our last one I want
you to see you're posing goose give me
your cell number six all right you're
anywhere in the Jersey dingus
right-handed sick all right so all the
boring details are done let's go all
right start with a I mean we should have
scaled a lot of a lot more options now
we only play the demo for 2k 18 but
there was not as many facial options
yeah in comparison so if you go Asian
right tell me tell me what you guys
think woody what are we looking for what
do you like here's there's only one
Asian head only one by the way sorry
that's all good oh no that's to number
seven was also oh you're right you're
right guys he's just saying he's more of
like your power forward there the other
guy
more like a guard should we go with
numbers showing no I dude just pick
whatever you want doesn't matter
I like mm no one saying to K 18 out
let's see maybe I'm wrong I thought
actual release date was tomorrow so I'll
go with this guy all right here we go
we're gonna go ham with the hair all
right so we got big afro September 19 Oh
God oh yeah
rotunda oh look at that that reminds me
of a Ala Depot I don't know if that's
true or not so I found these down here
it's the kind of like the lamella ball
look or we got a little bit amigos look
at the amigos
[Applause]
so chat what are we thinking I really
liked amigos look this is high top
tiered it's like you got stairs to climb
on Antonio Brown with love high top it's
high top steps is what's called where's
the rail er oh yes now we're going we're
going we're going migas chiefest pieces
Asians can't dunk I don't know y'all
mean could dunk yeah he's a huge man I
bet you I bet you Lin could dunk Jeremy
Lin yeah absolutely
you link it dunk here so MJ Jones 91
says cringe that's yachty not me goes oh
well I don't know my I don't know all my
rappers that see Devon Elliott says
that's yadi not me he goes okay so
that's confirmed
yadi that's what is the difference
between dreads in these jheri curl Oh
God
so do we want to do facial hair look at
all the facial hair options pick one do
you want to fear the beer you we're
gonna go to life if we're gonna go full
beard then we gotta go
yeah lumberjack yeah
and we certain type of uh alright so
that's pretty much all the event okay
for this is creating your player so yeah
you don't have scalars that's it well
here we go here we get here's the
scaling so okay so do we want to play as
a guard wing let's go wing you want to
go win this title wing let's go wing
this time we did Poincare last time
shooter score defender hybrid which is
like a row dude they got kupo I call
them the Greek freak giannis yeah can we
I don't want to be I definitely don't
want to be demar derozan I either want
to be klay Thompson Kauai or the Greek
freak so you you pick let's just be the
Greek fly about it things balanced
alright we want to make them we want to
max out his height I think it's six nine
is good you want to max my wingspan or
something do that what about this I
don't think so I think it's just weight
and height so you want to be a strong or
fast player I think like a to 220 220
Alan's right 220 where does it make the
jump maybe like 230 dang man you're a
pretty slow hybrid player then alright
like the Greek freak can't be like
hairless are 225 225
I think that's let's say make him as
tall as possible so cyborg man I
wouldn't do that although we're gonna
make a ezel fuel not happy with our hair
choices new line can you make it normal
daddy
okay so giannis is 220 all right 611
though oh whoa
that's fine let's give him a little more
height just a little bit more yeah your
vertical go down that doesn't whatever
that don't make sense to me but whatever
alright SiC confirm all right let's do
it alright so you're telling me that
this story is a little bit more
realistic and a little bit less cringing
right I mean it's not yeah it's a lot
less currency than 2k I think
I like the way that they build the store
such I will just hop right in let me
preface that it was the demo we checked
that but yes you mean that stories
though like millions of other kids you
dreamed of one day being in the NBA you
want it to be a star
and someday to rise above and become the
greatest to ever play you dreamed of
being the one but the road to stardom is
never he's cover breath there are
obstacles injuries and disappointments
adversity is universal it can happen to
anyone at any time and one day it
happened to you you went from being a
guaranteed lottery pick to a kid who may
never even play college ball again see
like this knowledge okay so like with
two cameras but Steven Naismith this one
is particularly disheartening because we
are two weeks into the season and one of
the top NBA prospects in the country
goes down potentially with a
season-ending injury a knee injury
that's a killer I couldn't agree more
when I heard he was carried off the
floor today all you can do is find
yourself hoping that he'll make it back
that's the bottom line well my heart
goes out to him because I didn't expect
this is the devastating injury it's
never good to have something like this
Aventine i watch the show pretty much
every teen doctor Brooklyn torn ACL
sprained MCL and a torn meniscus surgery
was scheduled but your game will likely
never be the same at the 2016 NBA Draft
your name is still mentioned not as a
prospect
but as a cautionary tale that's why he
should have went out of college as a
freshman and draft a record number of
underclassmen 30 of them undrafted and I
hope anyway that this is a lesson this
serves as an example to college players
I'm not talking about the ones who are
genuinely one in Dunn's the guys you
know are gonna be lottery picks I mean
the rest of them they're not they're not
sure shots you're not sure they're gonna
be lying to reason don't just use the
college system for a year thinking
you're gonna bounce it doesn't work like
nannies if you don't have the talent it
doesn't order you got to be cultivated
ladies please there you go again with
your blanket generalization you know how
you all max the war with me oh my lord I
can't I can't take it in my face you
can't just blanket lead aside this
should not be one of dogs or this should
be one it does you got to go it on a
case-by-case basis some dudes deserve to
be one of Dunn's
some people don't it's on a case-by-case
right basis that is my point thank you
for making it for me every kid thinks
they're the exception to the rule and
members of the media like um Stephen a
Smith or encouraging these kids to come
out early look max bottom line is this
you got to take this into consideration
you had two dudes they were called the
height brothers then you had Nick Howard
this kid has a license Thomas to college
very uh no doubt the second year he was
pretty good the here's the problem the
NBA it's not about pretty good you need
to be great on the collegiate Lauer's
one abreast level in summer leagues and
what have you in order for you to get
the stature that you deserve that's the
bottom line
you're pretty good ain't good enough
finish let me finish there's another
example I just say the hi brothers I
want to talk about one individual I was
talking about - what happened wasn't
done in a different way one year one a
CL injury later and look where he's at
now his future is clearly uncertain so
you gotta take advantage of that
opportunity because you never know when
an injury is gonna cost you everything
Stephen a listen to yourself listen to
yourself for a second you give one
argument for why a kid should come out
early a one in done situation I
I can give you 30 arguments this morning
alone why they should stay in school and
now you have to wonder what a kid like
Nick Howard who has given up his college
eligibility
does next what is he do next of all
don't sweat detect me he's our argument
or one AAG and it using the matter
that's number one number two the high
especially when they really really even
do it let me tell you what they need to
do max per game Ethan get back to
playing together
my sources are telling me the ACL injury
has been completely healed so go on a
pro-am circuit go in summer leagues do
what you got to do to get back on it out
together
remind everybody on what you want to
work because once you pull that off the
sky's the limit that's what they need to
do get back to playing ball together
because when people see what you can do
as one the other arguments don't really
matter like I said don't sweat the
technique boom i watch tape so I'm used
to kind of seeing the Stephen a Max
Kellerman kind of arguments back and
forth and that was pretty on point given
the subject matter of what if you're not
worthy I don't think it's creating a
little long for me okay they're long but
it's like introducing the story yeah it
set it up I like this so much better in
2k 18 where it's like this awkward like
everybody's got dumb nicknames and stuff
this is like it's a real like you got
injured so here we are so like our best
friend Nick you know you catch a game
yeah interesting interesting we got a
call on ESPN yeah definitely weird
and so like Nick wants us to like go and
play again you're you're the guy that
got into me yes I was gotcha so I'll say
yeah and he feels great ready to go well
you know we're playing NBA Live 28 18 or
18 which and we're going through the
story mode right now so so I got a bunch
of already 500 height so I'm gonna go
with this because I haven't gotten yeah
it's a gear so I could get new sneakers
the height let's say we already already
got some from my last year dude I never
have enough light where we got here in
this crate ooh oh yeah put that on it's
the it's the perfect time that that hair
though yeah apparently that's yachties
hair so we going yachty
hey game you see the game last night
that's right I don't think game is
actually that terrible of a nickname if
that was our nickname oh look who were
playing with Joe Keene I think Lance yep
so we're going to Rucker in New York
City and I think they're gonna show a
little intro about Rucker Park which is
cool it's like almost a it's
historically accurate but it's like
accurate to what basketball is today
especially like street ball in New York
City I've actually been to any like
official stuff at Rucker but I've walked
by a couple times the mecca of
basketball the original ruggedly began
here in 1987
found a permanent home uptown at PS 156
playground those early record a showcase
talents like Lew Alcindor who will
distilled and Earl the Pearl it's also
where Julius Erving became the doctor in
1974 the park was respectfully renamed
all : Rucker Park and honor the
tournament founded the many of influence
to grow through the ruckus since but
none more heavily than the late great
Gregg Marius founder of the EBC many
would argue that the rock is the
birthplace of true street ball and the
crossover dribble instead of a new york
city's pension for flashy guard play
there are few who can challenge that
after the legendary exploits of Rucker
alumni like rod Strickland rafer alston
and Kyrie Irving
I read Jersey boy stuff all banged on
can happen to anybody
at any given moment hit it's no wonder
that this unassuming uptown playground
has become the most widely recognized
street ball court in the world
welcome Park oh I like that goop shoe
said it's like 15 415 little mini
version of thirty four thirty it's good
point here we go Oh graphics look good
I'm diggin that pretty good it has been
like they did take like a year off
essentially there was no MBA live seven
vidiian there's like a mobile game in
2016 but no MBA alai of 17 so kind of
cool to see EA kind of coming back to
this I know you're a big college
proponent and I know if people on
college basketball that I wish football
game I would give anything
oh come on choking get it okay does this
have multiple camera views like UK it
does oh no your boy whose pocket picked
is that my boy Nick that guy those naked
thing oh no here you go here you go
oh I called that Pacis my bad I
should've his forgiving than 2k 18 from
what I've seen so far all right where's
my man oh is that my man all right are
we good we're good
all right let's get on our yacht ego go
get him oh oh okay start Oh littles
little jumpstart is lish there you go
out street objective you earned one
assist on a give and go if I got a oh
your other guys over there I'm not
useless we were playing PG last time
yeah okay okay get in Oh rebound nice
jokey with dangerous pass there's my
friend oh oh oh
miracle shine and one I'm now what a
foul on that I wanted a foul on that oh
my god yeah I keep forgetting you guys
saying you guys stick to him
my man's over here yeah I don't don't
get caught ball Hawking watching the
ball nice David Lee
man I hate those pants Deeley buying the
Chipotle for the old Warriors team as a
goodbye gift really it was like one of
the last things he did before after the
championship now he's on the Spurs and
they lost again sorry Dooley you served
us well
Oh ugly ugly no that's not a good Drive
it was a bad Drive why they told you
they just said they just said good Drive
those bad driving rebounds Oh delete get
out of here Oh big yadi yadi plays
basketball that's right Oh force I was
trying to do a spin but if I off it and
then it says like I'm shooting with my
with the trigger oh no way yeah man
there's a lot more crazy shot than just
this you know compared to uh-oh what
I've seen so far yeah I did did look
like it will yachty the rapper lil
yachty the basketball player Oh get him
get him Big Daddy money Oh what maybe
you don't have a Jay
that's like a guy palace here here we go
all right let's get something going
let's get it underneath your spacing
your team spacing is terrible
this guy's just jack oh god I'm a 7,400
oh yeah man I keep forgetting I'm using
some kinda neat guard yeah you made the
point you gotta guard the the wing oh
wow dude is that her boy again cuz man
he he's getting exposed then the coward
he's getting exposed so I could shoot
threes as as my position too right yeah
but I don't think you're great at it I
think you're more of a oh you're just
gonna throw King oh there you go can I
ask you guys this I don't know this game
seems a little bit more generous on some
of these plays but we'll see who's that
Naughty Dog this gameplay looks like
trash I think it's actually pretty
decent it plays a lot nicer than 2k yeah
you're saying oh man steal that steal
that no oh there we go break Oh No that
after the beautiful steel how do I miss
that find your guy okay switch switch by
your teammate there oh yo Keem get that
get the real healthy choice your jerseys
we could do it after the game it's only
Nick dad's at Jersey on I could have
wore KD I guess and really nice on it
nice that's right I'm a warriors fan
yeah hey haters gonna hate
not a fair-weather fan either so don't
say that i bandwagon yeah no he tased a
fan of the Warriors since Run TMC days
baby get that rebound nice neck there
boy back to the Sprewell and choke gaze
sorry PJ
here we go I wanna I want to talk for it
in the post baby are you trying to shake
him go ahead shoot down we're not close
swing you got seven seconds oh no
problem no I don't know no he doesn't
know that right maybe it's like all the
way on the sides are you think you like
a dream on yeah what top of the key I
don't know that we got to figure it out
on the runner that was Lance Stephenson
wasn't it I don't know it could see
actually I didn't look at that time
alright we're only down to come on I
don't know if live is live on the switch
I know 2k 18 is I don't know if live
I'll double-check that Oh what are you
doing pass was that Oh Annie's on I know
that's 2k I don't see it on I don't
think it is take my man down here oh oh
nice somebody lost their man on no ice
on the switch is only on ps4 Xbox one
for NBA live 20 18 or 18 2 K NBA 2k 18
is however on the switch that comes out
tomorrow oh oh yeah get in there that
was nice I think that's we're talking
about why should celebrate when I make a
shot a tie game here 10 10 there o'clock
for this game I think there is but you
gotta win by to take it wasn't
Stephenson that does not look like Lance
even now that doesn't look very good
actually joking no it looks no oh what a
play by this guy
[Applause]
nice block nice block oh come on Pete
yachty I don't know who's on my team I
don't want to toss it up are you gonna
shake him you're gonna give him though
oh you're gonna you Steph Curry step
back you can the step back I wanted to
be the hero
oh no there it's his first one to 21
that rebound here we go live is ya know
live on switch this to k18 watch your
stamina fam that is a good point Nick
watch your stamina watchin yeah you got
eight seconds here on the clock oh I was
all bleep up that was ugly you got a bad
shot selection there you got a -3 damn I
was at 79 you were I need to step it up
again back down slow all right come on
boys get some some easy assists here
oh he's got down low position on that
little guy man you got a got a post him
up Oh Joe Keene with the local yeah
there you go he would never do that in
the game come on Oh little dance dude he
crossed up a guy from like near the
three-point line no joking wouldn't do
that times I hate those shorts Oh
Ukraine home okay call for pass Nick I
wish that when I called for a pass it
would also it would go to yeah open shop
Iron Man minus one damn warrant I was
caught sleeping yeah alright Nick
don't leave your guy bro just focus on
the game here we go swing Oh sucks other
smash bro no hype bro pipe bro Smash bro
that's weird
bro dude is a straight ball hog yeah
this guy you're talking about you grow
to me yeah that's what Jason perks says
my ball hog
you're not creating for your team oh
there is there's there's your boy nice
go buy his guys slamma-jamma come on
hold that one to call for those pigs yep
for sure
thanks for tip young chance PA thank you
here we go here we go call for a pig l1
that yeah alright then have him roll oh
he didn't even set the pick yet didn't
even slip the picked up I think he had
him roll early oh here we go
layup although reverse nice there we go
you look you look good there where's my
man there he is I did say Smash bro
he's your hyper Oh Piper Oh Piper aw
Piper oh all right
tie game Chris is 21 I'd like to win
this game oh there's your Syria is your
hyper oh man dad dad fadeaway Deeley on
the fast break
yes
Oh Mike's hit me hit me hit me you can
do it l-3 to roll down Oh what is that
is not who I wanted to pass to at all
just know that the when you're whenever
you highlight a person it will hit a
point where you're you do weird where it
is like you see that arrow like if you
should follow that oh yeah oh good Deeks
there we go you caused that turn over
a lot of bunch up in the middle oh joy
keen Wow holding out of his mind person
you got to hold that heat Kirsten you
hold the pic yeah yeah yeah l wanted to
pick l32 role we got to set the pick
first then roll just like in real
basketball I wonder if we can play
one-on-one I know you can play
one-on-one in just like the training
yeah because you said you're playing
against oh yeah oh they got three
seconds to shoot good lock down the no
way
Oh bail out wait Stevenson with the
clutch count down here you're going for
the win are you going for some some
layups so good
let's go a reverse layup all right don't
let him have a three that's not your
guys I know I know my guys I hate you
guys wait well I guess was switch that's
fine that's fine no matter what you go
this is make them make them take it - oh
my god you guys I'm off the line you
hear this song in the background yeah Oh
get out of here push it ran up guy up
get this guy lay up for the wind it up
oh we got found yeah we got it there you
go good job Nick boom dynamite alright
that was pretty good what I end up with
league is 75 at the end man how was the
player game they got player of the game
oh that was sick szerik 78 we are
playing NBA live a team that which is
not on the Nintendo switch only NBA 2k
18 which comes out tomorrow / - guys no
problem Annie got body bumped alright
how we do how we do how we do all right
when W got some points cool got some
sheet height there's what Evensen the
guy that didn't look like Lance
Stephenson that's not bad
no you look - sis Oh photo I know but in
the game just now he didn't know what a
ttle so we'll play we'll do another game
and I think the next game is in Venice
California
so it's street ball on the west coast
nice and then we should play a
little heads ahead maybe yeah let's do
it we play like a regular game maybe we
can play a little one gotta look I got a
look at hot damn I wasn't looking at the
dribble moves I need to know those for
later
I haven't played live so it's one of
those another one of those moments where
I get to say I can beat Nick alright no
experience
so since I'm level 2 now I can pick
another dude ok your mid-range man yeah
I agree
your your mid-range is it's not good so
Paul George's jump shot sure we're gonna
acquire his jump shot mhm
ok Fiji's got a pretty solid jump shot
alright sick I wonder if we got any quip
the trade so this will be alright so
shop walking wind sprints post finesse I
think post I will do it for both of them
wow you haven't even gone in the past no
not at all but I think I should try now
alright so Nick texted us again thanks
for coming out game yeah how's it feel
good to be out there listen my agent
thinks we come out to Venice Beach and
playing the drew let's do it of course
I'm in do give us those points Wow 16
all right sick so too we're going out oh
so it's not that long of a story huh
the vet was looking just at the circles
well I don't know I I've really only
done like three or four games so I don't
know
alright see who we got here so I got
Blake you got Blake Griffin Kevin Love
where's Blake Oh areas like Nick Young
yeah swaggy P did you see his heat of
funny video today on Instagram he's he's
all fired up about his new jersey how
he's gonna be our sixth man and hello he
scores a lot but if he doesn't we'll
immediately bench him I don't know man
I'm kind of missing Clark
he gelled really well with David West so
I think there's gonna be a little bit of
a learning curve for our second unit
this year yeah another a long place like
no other fit with the cast of characters
sun sand and shoreline you can handle a
Venice Beach basketball brings a
completely different kind of beauty to
the beach a beauty made a long range
jumpers Metta World Peace level defender
and some of the best athletic ability in
the West and it ain't news since the
heyday of the og Ray Lewis dropping 50
on Michael Cooper in the 80s
since freedom Williams put up 75 in
college game since Ron Beals created the
trend of street ball legends pushing the
pros to their very limits under the
scorching California sunshine long
before baggy shorts and elbow sleeve
became a universal uniform a choice
every guard at Venice has been a menace
and the rule here is you reach we teach
teach your defense the definition of
pressure and big man pack a lunch it's
gonna be a long day down there to paint
out here the days along and the handles
are strong are you ready to get busy on
the beach in Venice let's go all right
Venice been to LA now oh look at it love
it all right those colors want to know
right now woman oh so I guess it's a
dark where the dark team it has to be
black jerseys in like black a little
practice layup
boom who's this big guy I know I look
like Joe Keene but it's not no it's
something not oh here we go blue like
Griffin
all right so it's Kevin Love on our team
guys [ __ ] over the other team I thought
all right 7 seconds 5 SEC's no you just
had to nobody was taking a shot you
could you could have found a better spot
find your dude on the wing oh [ __ ]
that's my gun stay on oh you lucky kid
rebound all right let's get some let's
get all big man downtown was open for a
second who's little yachty this task to
shy gamer I'm it's a rapper taking
Google long sloppy
I don't help hunter Anderson with his
really like lavish there we go Jersey
logo well lay up nice I think is he real
I never heard I can find out nice I
guess he is don't know who plays for
assuming that's the same person I'm
looking at late oh you got swag swag
he's got you right now swaggy P six
seconds
do something three two oh come on why is
that jumper so bad I had our plus two
jumper he didn't do anything I feel like
I'm hitting my I'm feel like I'm hitting
the bar at the right hand the right
centimeter yeah I think I am dude you
can't leave swaggy P yeah I got I got
screened they're open shot give you a
rebound though that's not fair
I got screened what am I supposed to do
I think they thought you could get
through it
can we see JJ reddick uh maybe at some
point he's definitely not in this game
right now it seems like there's like one
or two stars per one of these little
sessions here ooh Oh
four seconds home downtown
- one Jack it up nothing still she
trying to like move it around with get a
bad shot
don't lose swaggy oh this is what the
words gonna do oh he decides to drive
this got swag done by swaggy P swaggy P
is Nick Young nickname oh you had the
whole right side he gave it to you
oh we had big man on the on the cut
there this is tough though that was like
a walk strong go strong on it okay guard
you hunt your Anderson there does well
sick so he is real who do you play for
I don't know I'm trying to figure that
out Oh Bobby right I don't know who that
is either most of these guys are real
though which is cool
this is like Auburn Montgomery and NC
double-a I don't know if that's actually
it Oh backside to complete once we clean
all the way out 30 seconds 3 seconds
because me my god you watching too much
my bad I was watching come on Nick damn
the negative 3 for that that was bad
game up it's me Andy that's good D
that's me and Nick yelling this whole
game go ahead sheet up and down man down
uh-oh good help
that's break man whatever gets in the
corner just sits there
you can make your teammate shoot yes
that's true Willie Hopkins
he knows he's trying to level as
character what soon but you can get boys
in the shoot shots I guess for seconds
Oh
oh he can't guard you out there what he
said not to me oh wow good pass oh I
don't know kale oh [ __ ] okay I take it
back
I thought kala had a layup but I guess
it's a good swing for the three drop the
play draw it up all right went the wrong
way there it is a layups again oh man I
don't want you had him on the roll to
but that would we know a little bit
toughest 64 no bueno
was that what oh no your guys you're
gonna lose more points damn I just step
it up
still in the game no singing though well
I'm not really worried about the game as
much as I'm worried about no one run
more plays you gotta run plays man gotta
run some plays okay oh okay it says I
was like dude you just gave up a layup I
am blue by swag yeah I'm like what are
you doing
that worked out that could have been
that could have been bad yeah oh my god
I can't keep up with them a black hat
nice block oh he's quick well I feel
like swaggy Peas like a - and your
players more like a three especially
with your height and size oh no all
right think out Blake was there help man
jump in
did that no fouls in this mode huh yeah
cuz you've definitely found Oh Blake all
the way take it she do
hunter Anderson though why did I just
pass it I don't know I didn't even know
I had
oh three seconds on you I don't know why
you realistic though my donkey is been
the most realistic call in all of this
so far watching from Istanbul says Kenny
the king thank you welcome from Istanbul
hope you're having it absolutely I hope
everyone is having a solid Monday don't
forget we are live every day again spot
live at 11:00 a.m. tomorrow we'll be
doing some Destiny's children
that's our weekly Tuesday livestream
where we play destiny on reset destiny
to rather on reset day so we'll be doing
that tomorrow meme probably John Luke or
me and possibly Rob or some combination
there Wednesday is okay ankles broken
apparently Wednesday is the lobby our
weekly gaming talk show that's also at
11:00 so you should check that out oh
there it is hunter you got it there you
guys this guy's got to be player of the
game right now three for three
getting some rebounds get your man get
you a man after this game me and Nick
will be playing some one-on-one won't be
well maybe not like we're playing head
to head rather head for sure so if you
guys are curious put your fake online
bets in on who you think will win me or
Nick Oh take it this is yeah should be a
fun time
Nick's played at least thirty minutes to
an hour more than I have I have no
experience here on the wrong guy yeah
turned it a little steel here we're
gonna go to point on he did his little
swaggy P leg spread after he shot it
thinking he made it but he did not get
out of the post like three second risky
three billion seconds okay
I guess it only really calls three of
the key on you
that's what you should be doing that
should be doing that swaggy peas too
small to guard you [ __ ] it Sam
Oh Oh full court almost a full court
pass half court pass okay Blake ain't
gonna pick it back him down
oh right there oh look like you're gonna
dunk it decided oh there's help
I'm gonna go reverse it on them Oh ma'am
nice all right said there we go
all right no still waiting for to see
who's gonna bet on who oh no okay good I
thought he's I'm getting burned he's so
much faster than I am
I can't keep up all right that's why you
got but I'm bigger you know I'm the
bigger in the favor and post is post him
up yeah he can't guard that oh I would
not reset reset yeah call for down low
you go Oh were you guys swaggy oh and
one how's that not a foul there's a foul
on this roof on the street saw stuff
okay love Oh stay with Caleb boy I swear
on a hot-ass day I feel like he hasn't
done anything this whole game that's
because your guys been beating you all
day oh this guy too is real quick Curtis
Hopkins game rare pazzo says do you
prefer this over 2k I haven't played it
yet I only played 2k demo with Nick so I
can't say anything yet but Nick could
probably answer a little bit nice Drive
what do you think 2k 18 versus this so
far from ah I like this I like this
better
and it's sure it has something to do
with gameplay but it also has a lot to
do with it has a lot to do with the more
realistic story mode I don't really like
that for stuff oh because I felt like to
kit I mean we just played the I only
played the demo but I don't know the
like the interactions between characters
felt really forced the like story about
like you rut what is it called their
their story mode this is called the one
the other one is involved
now shoot I don't remember what it's
called somebody in the chat tell me I'll
look it up
I'm sure they'll be on top of it in like
two seconds
I like the story mode a lot better now
graphics was I think there are a couple
there are a couple players that don't
look as good as they could I think in
live but I think it's definitely an
improvement I don't know if you've
noticed but I've scored three in a row
now I think so I have it because I
didn't try to look up don't so don't
watch it yes it is unless I'm are the
journey the journey
oh the journey called the journey people
are saying my career oh wow I wasn't
playing you leaving again oh you lost we
lost because of that yeah you hit that
300 yeah Chris so we definitely have not
been paid we've never been paid to do
any of that kind of stuff so we are not
paid to livestream this you're crazy to
think otherwise just to give you guys a
heads up also me and Nick don't review
games no we don't review games just our
personal opinions ayat like I said I
haven't played it so I cannot speak to
it it's just Nick's opinion of him
playing both games for roughly around
the same amount of time which is like
you know an hour or two so that's not a
huge sample size obviously but that's
just us trying to answer a question
based off people asking damn I'm or
Sisson here all right let's do this
all right let's try replacing 1v1 30 i
already connected that controller should
be good and turn on
if you want you tip us now good all
right yeah once I figure out where the
best spot is there usually only plays
destiny that's not 100% true that's
partially true
oh shoot well three are you both
basketball fans yes gamer pazzo he's in
New York Knicks fan I am a Golden State
Warriors man I've been since I was kid
but I'm gonna say it just sermons where
I prefer college basketball to the NBA
by lap laughing slap slapping just p88
there will be a review at some point I
don't think it'll be right after this
livestream no all right here we go so
you know play now saying this already
come on stop Tristan Thompson by himself
and I like how Durant is like one number
better than only Celtics king rica rico
saying live is better than live is
better sad GK people don't open eyes
just are you playing the Celtics yeah
are you playing the potential 2018
finals here potential change the time on
this to speed anything up where we good
now I'd switch to green
all right you keep backing out I do yeah
hit tip off there you go like what are
you doing look at this hose dribble
moves you gotta flick the stick okay
so Stan spliff wants to know why do I
prefer college ball the NBA because I
think that college players play harder
NBA players there's more there's more
defense there's more passion there's
more there's they're not fixed I must
say it right now I think that a lot of
these finals go as long as they go for
reasons we can't control just saying you
really think that I do I really do you
think top rights okay oh yeah I think
it's fine
let's try that let's just try that let's
see how that goes guys I don't know if
anything's at the top right we're gonna
find out here Oh Steph let's go Steph Oh
Nina new Nike Gordon Hayward I don't
like how big that nega Jersey our Nike
thing was on that a sweater but here we
go here we go
dubs I can't let the dubnation down oh
you can beat Horford sighs oh God oh you
go downtown
Oh No can we change the reaches of you
sure I hate this sure
okay well do you want to change it now
yeah Oh God
Oh see where is I know it was like d-pad
in 2k which way would you like to be
where do you want to kick you pick what
you want well just by the way whatever
is most convenient for you because I
don't want to hear excuses all right
there we go
that feels much really oh why this would
take this would never happen
Steph would never be guarding Kyrene he
would never Garth I read in a real-life
situation
oh no he would never be clay would be
honour play wood real here wait yes clay
wood a hundred percent
oh [ __ ] oh you actually have to finesse
the layup huh felt a little bit of the
rumbling on my on my way up to your step
would not have missed that later I guess
I guess technically I guess who's
Heyward actually I think we could we
could hide oh no no we could hide him on
smart we put stuff on smart we'd put
clay on Kyrie and then Durant could
guard oh shoot Durant could guard
don't get underneath she's small all day
tank gardening oh they call foul
my babies can't guard KD here Durant
Elena and you're asking be dunked on
that was the euphoric Tribble that's
correct
oh and it hit Hayward in the head the
poet
watch the ball hit him in the head after
the back oh come on oh yeah give me the
little shimmy Oh No oh it doesn't okay I
must have just hit it early oh gotta get
that ball right step on him cuz
apparently just drove on okay yeah so
you gotta wait I didn't wait for it to
go I didn't wait for it to go up I kind
of hit it early
Oh box out he's got shooter Durant got
shooter yeah
there we go
send me a picture a
I don't know I just pulled up oh it's
because I had that place oh yeah got the
healthy fans for food and I blew by
Hayward no I don't want to watch that
replay yeah we want to see that what a
block down garbage block however you get
out of here Kevin Durant nope oh that's
a shooter you know that he's gonna have
some leeway and you left that's a major
league you left him so oh oh you had me
crossed up oh damn
that is a very exaggerated jump oh I
need help waiting real life every time I
see Kai Reed barring step and what what
where was a foul on Al Horford yeah
shouldn't be shouldn't be getting under
the hey dude how is this free-throw
percentage really only 89 really I don't
know I don't know this is your team why
doesn't it go oh do I have to hold you
to hold it you can hold it
I thought it went up on its own oh no
hold hold hold alright well that's great
ESPN NBA Mondays hold in then let
release yes oh oh oh three come on Ref
Oh Rose years in already okay curtsy
pair let's the starters play for a while
swaggy Pete it's just like the regular
Warriors oh my god that with the
fast-break rebound
they'll pull ups all right this is
falling apart quickly
that's because Kyrie is out I don't know
why he's out so early did you get hurt
come on we didn't pay you that big money
come on Iggy hey that's it give him that
like really derpy like what kind of look
with that thanks Sam Jones I don't know
if you're being serious or not Oh
Livingston's in though I'm one of the
Morris brothers Oh
Tatum oh we got box out I got it
Tatum's a stud
Hayden is a stud to see not a starter or
something
Ascot you're playing like so far up on
you know let go let go dream on
what is down there from one three
seconds you just cut their Brody left
him no way
go washer you play maybe if you play
some defense something oh where is my
boy
where is Kyrie how is he on the bench
right now isn't you played it all hey
get up there hustle Oh what do you mean
closely-guarded forces it the nice
little swing pass Horford can hit threes
now Oh pass break now if you shoot like
that all right there we go down dalla
only down for dude he should have made
that layout Oh Omar Gatsby maybe Curry's
still not on the court wing swings
although short
I'm so sorry swag
let's get ball movement I like I like
the Bob he's out of bounds
Oh Gatsby that's a mismatch who's that
on the wing over there Omar Gatsby Seenu
why would you go all the way around
I had the whole front side of it where's
my where's my where's Rick and Katie and
everyone I don't know I don't have any
money there except for Hayward and Tatum
Oh got you some downs passes in the
non-bang become sloppy without my
starters there's Tatum get some points
on the board kid let's go I don't like
that clay got subs early didn't get any
look give that give that all right I
gotta get Kyrie on the floor he's using
Perry I need everyone else to the hole
first units out Oh cut that out
Wow looks like him are we bringing on
people are saying QK this has a stiff
movement that to cash flow to it
yeah what is the prop why is he been out
this whole game did he injure is he oh
maybe he's out you haven't had so huh I
just got more he's open and I good help
that was a little delayed cuz I
I hit the pathway before buckets wet ooh
oh you can't see me oh good help Katie
oh that's good passing with the boyars
good passing time out yeah you need it
where's a is a Kyrie hurt because my
guys are good
he's fun
oh ho let's get you a veil in jubail
lucky should be it Oh what am i doing
this wrong leave Hartford
there we go
yeah
good oh let's death lighten up you oh
you're gonna go with the full starting
lineup now forget it
I'm okay you can do that yeah I watch a
veil with Kyrie ends should be there is
Oh
help help help bad pass doesn't matter
Steph Curry he doesn't miss that's right
you're not what you gonna do about it
road when you're in the yellow it's on
it going to my fault it is shooter oh
good kitty Katie you stay there okay get
out of here
oh that was
[Music]
swing here for you miss two layups gonna
go for it goes for the basket I need
help
oh that's ours right night through down
what you do that out
how does he throw it to nobody
that's fine oh I need help and one it's
just like well that's get broken you
gotta love swing gone here little swing
now he looks pretty good there that's
pretty good
Kyrie I don't know yeah the eyes are
bugging me out a little bit all right as
it should be uh-huh
boy Selena what was this percentage soon
no I did not
nope oh nice steal what are you crazy
hey man I'm playing Warriors bass yeah
what about it you got a problem my
worries basketball
wha come on keep losing the ball be up
in the lead now damn playing Warriors
basketball right now is what I'm doing
why is Gatsby guarding freakin Heyward
Raymond would have been put in the game
already I hate this clay he's set hmm
this is a terrible match up right here
down six and a half and could have been
awesome we had internal probably dream
on not back in the game there and guess
who plays the whole second I don't know
I would play Gatsby or I mean I would
have played Raymond and Iggy and ran the
death line up if I got up if I hadn't
put Kyrie in I think he was only in for
like the first two minutes skip it oh
look at this let's get the highlights
and McCaw hasn't even played a minute
that's like crazy no music Jeff Van
Gundy to carry the load
particularly take that let me take that
for me
salute Joe the way both of these teams
are turn the ball over it's uh Morris
Morris get off and once I hop I just do
the dream on flex on them dream on flex
on them that's celebration look at with
the left
no out-of-body euro flowery throw
shooter Zaza Pachulia here down in the
yellow of the high yellow it's like a
c-plus oh here we go
big matchup here's you kidding me right
now
Oh Oh shake and bake baby shake and pick
all the way Oh
Crabtree one just got shoved out the way
get out of the way Al Horford nice play
that's what the Warriors do it's all
about passing and hitting those threes
oh crap
hurry too fast Oh way to stick ways to
handle
I understand dead dead on perfect
perfect trajectory it's just so good
it's just fun watching the Warriors
spread the ball I do too Jeff Van Gundy
come on down 11 got lost on to you
to the corner fires a nice cross sport
oh it's a loose ball
get the rebound come on get in there hey
des
but if you think about it this is
exactly how the Warriors play up-tempo
what was that it's not my pointy towards
and then just for the cherry on top you
know
and then you have to call timeout then
you got call timeout right because this
is what the Warriors dude she's got call
timeout because we got a little run you
know put some turnovers i got rekked
call timeout hey play what's up seen
between three somebody it hurts Boston
you play in the paint that's what he's
playing Boston that's Kirsten Hudson
Houston sorry Boston do you change your
player man change your players is that
yes yeah and close to bales in Java
muggy today I need a pick
[Music]
take it to the house Tatum oh come on
they're gonna play better than that
again
falling apart the shots are just like
what do you do in the NBA and one thanks
Harry
bailout why don't you scream I I got a
screen more you're right King Axl I'm
just used to that we're just spreading
the floor with the Warriors and trying
to hit the open man
oh god I did it again early early yeah I
was trying to skip through this part
three free throws out three triple I
should have made all three they just
keep forgetting how this free throw
system works I'm trying to skip through
a certain cuts and stuff oh [ __ ] that
Iggy I can't make a lamp right now [ __ ]
literally cannot make a layup oh that
was at the top of the yellow damn money
know how it feels
oh dude that was top of the yellow that
was a bad shot though nothing I don't
think I saw were third Boston dude is
taking lots of hard yeah I think I don't
think I made a point in the third
quarter you know you don't have talent
should been believe land
I had that oh Jesus come on where your
basketball Oh two-pointer that was a
three ways Oh dream on Jesus come on
I went for the steal thought I got it
did not finally there we go Oh back him
down that stop back him down vintage
doesn't Tatum shoot threes he shot
[Music]
that's not you only when it goes over oh
my god are you dude don't you know the
rules
not when it's on top only way if it goes
over I can't believe that one end Oh
shorty let's go oh that's
I don't know what Janet's it's all the
way on the outside no y-you got excited
there what are they
who we got now on the floor bounce pass
they're good hands by reaching oh dude
how is that reaching my whole back was
do you get out the way bail out
there we go
come on oh why didn't you take it clay
you've got a reed down there gotta box
him out oh I don't know why clay didn't
take that that three in the corner
though I Rianna he's like six feet
taller
come on with these three oh my gosh
exactly how the words play though he
space the floor on a dribble penetration
by clay kick-out
Neela three all right kid in a tough
shot Wow we don't need a timeout eggy
this game's over
you call her no I didn't call it the
game called it for him
I where's McCall swaggy P in here we
need get Patrick we'll call we're gonna
get the we're gonna get the young looks
on who's that Omar Gatsby that's good
huh keep thinking of bounce pass with
the Horford
it's alright planning a small I know I
just want you to know that stuff is
capable of this of what King I thought
that was gonna go on I really did what
are you doing testing his reign Thank
You K you can make that walk yourself
oh you would never leave Steph this far
they come back no way - way too late
anything 47 all right
live is a good game glad it returned
well that's what Thomas a pretty good
return it let's see if we can please
Jack in threes that's what I do 93 six
or 3x that's what you gotta do when
you're the Dubs let's see if we can play
would have been bad ass if Craig made
that shot what are we doing can we play
1v1 so I'm not sure if we can let's say
also if you guys want to see certain
teams let us know we also will do one
more head-to-head also wmba that's true
is in which is cool oh yeah there you go
play WNBA all right
popcorn Jones 77 says Pluto be a move is
right trigger and something King Axl we
haven't had reviews out yet for 2k or MV
alive
18 so those are coming soon oh can we do
1v1 can you control one yes we can one
are you gonna be humble on the ball
whoa oh shoot that's cool I'll be the
Greek freak I guess I'm the law oh did I
select it and they just selected for
both of us so na GU he has a like half
an hour more experience what that means
anything huh no no I played probably a
half hour I have like until today I am
plating same with two kid oh here we go
I pick your player you gonna pick Alonso
right yeah all right well you're gonna
get Greek freaked all right lon so let's
see what you got all right here we go
what what i swatted this Lonzo ball he's
a legend
Oh God see ya shoulda stayed on him how
come I get the ball back oh no I know I
do
oh god why does it take so long - oh
it's also not keeping score either yeah
well we know dude how is he not walking
that you were to eat that up for
breakfast
wow what was that Lonzo place of deep
bro alright here we're gonna try to play
some better Dion NIC here because
clearly he's been I'm gonna take a jump
shot next I'm not gonna go for the
basket Oh
see sheet reason I don't really watch
him oh no oh yeah you're right he
doesn't have that really weird release I
wonder if it's in this game
damn
do you hate that release and rhythm off
that little cross oh damn
all right I'm up I like to write now
oh you are curious oh you just gave up
Oh what oh so I need to stop yeah you
need to stop in a bucket at least I oh
come on I thought I had you there
recovery you gross
[Music]
oh come on that was it the all the way
at the yellow you're clear
oh you almost blocked out I was late
oh wow I want I want left committed to
it alright next three points I'm gonna
play a little WNBA come on for the reach
baby Oh
see you had to go for the steal the only
way all right that's one
Lonzo balls releases 100% disgusting
damn he's not very good the 82 though
that's pretty high that's pretty high
for a rookie oh I did not mean to do
that I just tried to do dribble moves
and I yeah I silently held the right
state Oh what oh I still got the ball
I don't know hesitation they're a
wonderful one one uno uno stay with them
stay with them oh really
okay come on Lanza this is our chance I
just stepped out of bounds didn't say
anything okay Oh
get the ball
damn I thought you're gonna mess the
social for the rebound
r21 you
oh wow lawns are stronger than hunting
Koopa huh sighs it that's how I say all
right here we go
I need stop you here nope all right oh
yeah okay last we're gonna do WMA here
as the last match of the day so quiet
Irina won't be one
yeah no commentator looks like no come
on bounce the music that louder this is
I'm pretty sure the first game with wmba
in it all down I'm gonna be super it's
supposed to be good Antonio is pretty
good
be sparks in Candice's the Mystics are
pretty good too bird oh that's the UH
that's what's-her-name from Miss Parker
well yeah Candice Parker I'm saying
that's what's-her-name from you come you
know all right here we go
put your bets in I'm Eric I'm playing
the Seattle team I want to say it's a
song fish by not you know and that's
Nick he's playing as the la sparks box
Candice pakka tip-off we are the Seattle
Storm
dude she's so good it's not even funny
UConn basketball won all those national
championships because of this girl which
one the one that has the ball right now
sue Burt yeah oh here we go oh no oh my
goodness
oh not sue bird what's your name number
30 okay
all right Candace Parker what up and one
[Applause]
buzzing Hannah sparkling religious
hearts oh wait okay
the phallus apart Kenz Parker nice wmba
Staples Center
Oh
yeah that's every time they Stewart
Breanna Stewart right that I will take
your word for it
I don't know what um what certain
advantages are I don't know who shoots
threes well can ya
Parker I think he's looking it's
pleasing the inside right down
nice will came off a little pick Sue
Bird movie yet blame the nice shot I was
the region and one nah dude and 100%
valid oh my god oh she missed it wrong
one she missed the blatant cross-court
pass it hurts me so much
let's find out oh nice
that was ugly Oh worked out
layup wow that worked out oh let's go
steal oh we gotta wait for some help
wide open nope maybe she's not a 3-point
shooter no idea seal the lane right
Braun Stewart's face let's go what are
you doing I think she can but she's more
down
I need to find out who my team shoot
please Oh Candace Parker ken oh you
should took that basket Sue Bird oh she
can't - bang alright here we go
WMA is lit this cool I gotta find 85
what sleeve
this is pretty cool I like this do you
think that the MBA at some point will
have logos in the jerseys like that or
is it just I know this I don't know
where you would put the logos on NFL
jerseys though because the numbers are
so long where would you put it thank you
Subaru word good college
I know he's pretty well making it
difficult to get to the basket
hands up hands up are we back oh I see
what people are asking what's what is
Swedish on their jerseys yeah I have no
idea what's up loose cast krasin Berg
nice has a high preacher percentage it
clearly all right here we go with a
fast-break layup at the end of the
quarter kind of that would have been
sick terrible all right was that only
first word she can't see freeze damn
firstly the game
come on sparks come on sparks you better
make your your all your shots not just a
little layup going here no locked okay
no jump shot either
no no bueno
nailed it oh yeah call timeout you need
it rough blows the whistle we're
struggling here
two very good already yes yes
I put all my starters back in I got
think that's what you're doing thinking
about what sounds yeah
- another lens hello hello oh yeah she's
not related to Larry Bird as no carb
egde Brown Stewart get your hands out of
here Oh shorty
all right get a little game here going
I don't know if I necessarily like the
jerseys this large on the WNBA jerseys
guys do like I do like the new ones in
the NBA and like the top corner earlier
I think the GE logo on the Boston looks
so good rebound we've an m1 get fouled
she got fouled with point one hey man
tell your AI to stop reaching in road me
you bumped me did you see it no foul
whatsoever okay get out of here Breanna
Stewart she's always the one that
doesn't look good I'm sorry wide open
The Sims Odyssey Sims Mario Odyssey Sims
Candace take it you bad bad release way
too early
this is a cool feature though I like
this I like having wmba oh yeah oh yeah
nothing rebound rebound rebound buckets
whoa no problem guarded sometimes you
just gotta force to play [ __ ] I tried to
reach nobody there get after it
I had the whole lane swing swing
how did she make that can't believe man
there are two hands on the ball okay
[Music]
seal this off oh yeah that's good it's
pretty good
still down one though I have no idea no
right
oh and one just faster than everyone
else let go please just end this and
place Cavs versus the Celtics or
something we can stop at halftime well
you guys don't enjoy those it was fun I
like it yeah I'm winning in a minute
take can't just shoot threes the whole
game I just don't know who shoots threes
on this team that's why here's the NBA I
know which guys can shoot threes I whoa
I still play the same way I will plays
the Knicks I'll play a half I'll play is
someone operable who's comparable I
don't know I have no idea better make
that I'll say you better make that layup
Sue Bird and one from steel SIA
oh yeah oh come on Miss a layup like
that with nobody around
four minutes gone by in the second and
it's a tie ballgame
yeah again
chilling it down low I don't know why
she's frontin air when she's gotten
Jenks place
what just happened I was on my way I was
on my girl throat and somebody would
left her wide open lock that Breanna
Stewart now on the court thank god she's
on the court there no she's not
no that's a different that's a different
oh wait yes she is she is she's up there
yes sir let's go
lock it up okay okay good point here big
point here 14 seconds Oh
daggers play up play up Oh
let's go Schubert and like a chat now
cuz he can't catch up I just go look at
shout oh my goodness buckets bucketz oh
man unreal two birds stepping it up when
she need to hit the three goes up one I
don't want the curse on these streets
but that was [ __ ] go play the Knicks
versus OMAP I'm feeling good man that
was such trash a half court real good
neck you don't understand I feel real
good right now Wow live you even have
Jordan I'm not sure about that I think
he's into Katie solid you threw it up it
just happen to go in I felt really solid
Nick what about the first two three
don't go up though
alright that's that's good that's a
legit
actually I know what people do not if we
please no you can't this why I mean you
play the Knicks they can't be that bad
they're not that good
they're fine the Knicks look they got
some a t-shape label I can't play the
Lakers they would kill me nugget or the
the okay how about uh pelicans that
taste huge Kelly's are too skewed do i
do Lakers Lakers take your loss like a
man Nick take your loss like a man are
you kidding me yeah take it off I take I
take losses when I lose fair and square
not when their hey I was up you still
had Randy - yeah I was up one stop Nick
I was up - even I was up - then you try
to pull the ball upcourt and I stole it
and I happened to make a [ __ ] three
not gonna lie about the [ __ ] three
but I still technically could have ran
the clock on you after I stole it Shane
did he watch the chat yeah i watch the
chat I'm looking at it right now
what'd you get what you got to say chat
oh the Sixers that would have been a
good call Leon my fault
Oh sort of an interesting only gonna
play happy why are we wearing white only
playing half I played all oh I didn't
mean to do buckets now we're even
my kids are who's feeding you want to
start it over yeah
I'll go pick the Fillies music you hear
yeah I picked Philly okay are you doing
me I don't know you do it I'll go pick
Philadelphia sounds weird quick game
sorry
actually it wasn't be a sue bird as a
good shooter I agree she doesn't get you
supa bluey says he said super is a good
shooter like yeah evidence in those last
two three she shot to help us win the
game Jewel and B we got JJ reddick good
boogy boogy
he said the a bad word there who a
rapper so you drop the slur there how I
stopped waves less ROP I think I think
if your defense is good health defense
that's how the word stopped a lot of the
layups but if you don't it's gonna be
tough here we go let's skip all that if
there you go
money on me if you want Billy money on
Nick if you want the Knickerbockers and
somehow indeed lost that that tip-off
which is oh you got the oh I went for
the steal Joel the New York
knickerbockers Knickerbocker rookie took
me I don't even think he is he actually
gonna start I have no idea I'm assuming
yes I mean everyone's putting on the
starting line oh right both strolling
nobody came in to help is he injured
bolt yeah I know
there's my boy okay so Joel gets over it
does not challenge a shot over porzingis
looked way too short in team he looks
normal size
just Oh Ben Simmons finally gonna get a
year's worth of basketball here play
mellow shook mellow Hardaway jr. really
expensive
oh em be don't that the sound that it
makes sounds like a high school gym like
this the court sounds man I haven't
touched mellow lucky side of the rim
Joel eat the whole play I was trying to
set up Redick Wow blocked and stolen
sick
jay-j still got the stroke tattoos yep
he's hardcore now oh there you go JJ JJ
pull-up
oh no I messed that up Joel he's too
small for you porzingis has got us down
steal that from him
clap clap
I really thought Mela was going this
year I mean I still think there's a
possibility though rebound how are you
getting out rebound down there guys
go where's in God the Latvian King pull
the short but luckily no one was there I
think it's it when no one's there it has
a higher chance of going in for things
like on a timeout this problem douse
kiss no one's doubts kissing here get
out of here
Oh
while the old veteran oh why you playing
off of him i doing why didn't you shoot
that jaw
we know prison Oh
porzingis challenge he always had it I
thought the process trust the process
the process this is like watching the
actual next play
oh we drew it up we got the swing to an
open three all right Nick's got a half
two catch up
I mean a quarter by the crowd because
the team played so poorly and with so
little effort I forget they had him
Faustus
now she's got a shot oh let's go oh my
god dude Bayless why oh no now excuse
two sessions
I can't buy a basket Oh Steph just can't
buy a basket let's go hit your layup or
Neely and one Johnson come on I'm here
just like watching my own team come on
Nick you're better than this I believe
in you that was drone Stan spliff I'm
glad someone believes in him
oh gosh
is it like turned on easy on his side
it's my basketball i.q Nick what it is
all about I got Steve Kerr my head I got
Steve Kerr in my head oh Joella beep
yeah yeah yeah that's a good that's a
good girl roster I've got three
potential scoring guards oh my god cows
kiss - gourd guard one of the best
offensive players in the league stay
down south kiss
oh hello Tilly jumped okay oh go get
that bolt
Stauskas
whoo next time I'm in Nick's head to
something he's getting desperate this is
so frustrated I don't even know like
words don't describe how frustrating
this is play we cheer up contested and
in space
give me heart away just like senior team
senior
or join me so Fernando on their rebound
rebound joel porzingis porzingis passes
are so bad i understand i'm like passing
it's a triple coverage
oops oh you can't actually try for the
alley okay I was trying to lob the whole
time to Joelle because he's open on the
plane almost Lappe
user oh oh
reaching that's an all-star call right
there it's an all-star call I clearly
got all ball it looked all ball but for
real on the on the court but who knows
oh you gotta watch it I don't want to
timeout we don't need it yeah calls all
the time out its senses momentum gotta
leave starters
redick's looking to get free off the
screen oh god JJ reddick is back on the
court he's been on the court no bueno
cyan play when he was the magic while
back magic Knicks games
like what
okay you didn't even try to shoot there
I didn't see I didn't shut off fine make
it interesting they're playing as two
worst teams in the Eastern Conference
Knicks definitely Philadelphia there's
more potential for them succeed this
year than any years past long as Ben
Simmons to stay healthy but they are
definitely not
Oh
Hardaway jr. with the anticipation that
beautiful no way away yeah I should have
took my time there I stopped 42 seconds
a lot of times like it's rush JJ
Oh 3 3 right 3 yeah I can't believe
that's a ballad oh I jump straight up
that's fine
here we go we got we got a situation
here it's like the Reggie Miller what
Reggie Miller did sizzling work I saw a
photo a couple days ago of Phil Jackson
riding the subway it's pretty funny how
far he's fallen here we go all right got
a game here only up for 33 secretary a
smart man would run the clock here
well bet that smart man oh I was trying
a little Ben's own hand down man down Oh
Joel embiid cherry picking just like it
is like the next just like Philadelphia
I'm gonna bring a and they pass it right
to the value a like 15-point lead
no oh good game Nick 30:28
yeah I don't even think porzingis scored
in that I don't think so you there you
didn't run plays for it man
yeah I show you how the Knicks to play
anyways I really appreciate everyone
tuning in on this fine a Monday morning
that was NBA Live 18 which is out since
last Friday check that out if you guys
are into it
the story mode seemed a little bit
better than the 2k 18 experience we had
NBA 2k 18 yes again we only played that
demo though so hard to say I'm a 2k 18
comes out tomorrow in 19th so you can
check that out too we also live scene
that so we can prepare them if you want
to that's on YouTube but other than that
we'll see you guys tomorrow 11:00 a.m.
by doing Destiny's children Wednesday
Lobby 11:00 a.m. she live stream every
day at 11 a.m. so if you haven't served
and whatnot please do that so that you
guys get notifications until next time
me and Nick are out until basically the
next sports game peace out peace there
Wars
[Music]
the Knicks have done themselves a bit of
a hole after two quarters they don't
have a single player thank you claimed
double figures and score